I'm so glad that some of our
conversations are on meditation so I
have a number of questions that I I get
on meditation uh what type there are
just many many many types of meditation
and I suppose they're probably almost
all good I've only experienced
Transcendental Meditation but there's uh
the type of meditation that I do is a
mantra Transcendental Meditation I think
there are number of them that have
mantras and the way it works is there's
a sound that you repeat in your mind
mind that takes your thoughts away from
your thoughts and puts them into that
sound for example M might be an example
and you repeat and you sit there quietly
and you repeat and the greatest problem
you're going to have is impatience
you're going to go into that state of
meditation and you're going to get
restless and that tells you you need to
meditate because if you can't sit there
and transcend and get rid of your
thoughts you're going to be in trouble
and think about the power that you have
when you can go into that nothingness
and experience that it's like going on
vacation and also being given the gift
of creativity and equinity how did I
learn to meditate The Beatles taught me
not I mean not literally what they did
is they went to India and they came back
and they told everybody about
Transcendental Meditation and I thought
well okay that sounds cool I'll try it
and so I went to um a place a little
townhouse where they uh taught
meditation I brought my flowers I paid
my fee and so on and I learned then
Transcendental Meditation and you know
thank God for it so when do I meditate I
meditate usually in the morning before
breakfast usually in the evening before
dinner uh I try to I'm not always
faithful to that and then also uh when I
have the need you know I could feel the
difference between being centered and
having that Equanimity and not when
there's stress when there's tensions
when there's big things sometimes
Weighing on me and I uh then know I just
need to go meditate and I can go into
some quiet spot and be there for 20
minutes and it just goes all off me all
that and then I come out of it and I
have a Clarity and an equinity that lets
me deal with whatever it is